[Musique]
un bon soir mardi 13 avril bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 c'est
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale tout
de suite les titres de cette édition la
crise sanitaire a modifié les habitudes
des déplacements des actifs en ile de
france l enseignement du baromètre
annuel alphabet france ifop retour en
force de la voiture émergence de
mobilité alternative nous parlons de ce
sujet avec sami cryan de la start-up
versaillaise entropie qui travaille sur
la mobilité s'est proposée par le parc
espace rambouillet une fois par mois des
ateliers entre rap à ses résidents sont
organisées à l'ehpad de gaz rend c'est
ce qu'on appelle la chouette thérapie
l'objectif de ces rencontres avec les
animaux rompre le sentiment d'isolement
et d'ennui et participer au bonheur des
personnes âgées
enfin direction au poids si à la fin de
ce journal la piscine des mignot a
rouvert son bassin extérieur après six
mois de fermeture des créneaux avec une
jauge maximum ont été mises en place
pour s'adapter au contexte et
épidémiques et les habitués sont bien
entendu heureux de retrouver les lieux
malgré les fraîches températures du
moment
mais avant de développer ses titres jean
castex devant l'assemblée nationale cet
après midi le premier ministre a proposé
aux députés un report d'une semaine des
élections régionales et départementales
prévues les 13 et 20 juin
celle ci serait donc ajourné au 20 et 27
juin le but laissé une semaine de plus
au mairie pour préparer l'organisation
du scrutin et bénéficier de jours
supplémentaires pour la vaccination
l assemblée nationale débat ce soir
autour du sujet le sénat demain mercredi
et des discussions suivies d'un vote
consultatif
une proposition au lendemain de
l'annoncé des résultats de cette
consultation lancée par le gouvernement
auprès des maires concernant le report
des régionales et départementales
justement sur les vingt-quatre mille
élus qui ont participé 56% se sont
prononcés pour un maintien des deux
scrutins le chiffre monte même à 76% et
d'avis favorables pour les édiles du
département des yvelines
la crise sanitaire on a eu de multiples
conséquences sur notre vie de tous les
jours et le sujet de la mobilité n'y
déroge pas dans la région ile de france
qui compte plus de 12 millions
d'habitants bon sens mais quel ennemi
d'euros de la rédaction de tv 78 ce que
les modes de déplacement des franciliens
ont évolué ces derniers mois en raison
du co lead de lakovic 19
eh bien oui à grégory un les franciliens
se déplacent différemment depuis un an
et la pandémie de kobe 19 les chiffres
parlent d'eux mêmes selon une étude de
l'institut ifop 20,1 pour cent des
actifs interrogés ont déclaré avoir
modifié leur mode de déplacement
domicile travail depuis le premier
confinement ces changements sont
majoritairement des initiatives
personnelles mais dans un tiers des cas
c'est une demande de l'employeur
mais quelle est la principale solution
privilégiée par les déplacements pour
les déplacements des franciliens alors
selon l'institut ifop le moyen de
déplacement privilégié reste la voiture
en 2020 jusque là pas de surprise mais
on a une vraie tendance à la hausse les
trajets entre le domicile et le lieu de
travail représentent 52 % des
déplacements soit 7 points de plus qu'en
2019 alors qu'on l'avait plutôt une
tendance à la baisse ces dernières
années avec notamment des franciliens
qui se tourner vers les as transports en
commun à noter également que la plupart
du temps les ces automobilistes restent
seuls dans leurs véhicules seulement 1 7
% pratiquent le covoiturage
là aussi les spécialistes avaient prévu
une hausse de ses trajets à plusieurs
dans les prochaines années mais ce
chiffre n'a pas évolué en 2020 sûrement
à cause de la pandémie
retour en force de la voiture est ce que
pour autant des solutions de mobilité
alternative ont été aussi trouvé oui
grégory là encore en région parisienne
on voit de plus en plus de piétons dans
les rues sur les trajets courte distance
40 % des franciliens qui ont opté pour
une nouvelle mobilité pratique désormais
régulièrement la marche à pied pour
aller au travail c'est également en
région parisienne que la part
d'utilisateurs de transport électrique
est la plus importante note 5 9 %
d'utilisateurs de vélos à assistance
électrique contre 3% sur la moyenne
c'est la moyenne nationale et 3% de
trottinettes à assistance électrique là
aussi ces chiffres ont augmenté sur léa
derniers mois merci michael pour toutes
ces précisions et on continue justement
à parler de ce sujet avec mon invité par
visioconférence amis kraiem bonsoir nous
sauve grégory
fondateur et sio2 la start-up entropie
elle est issue des travaux de recherche
de l'institut vd comme à versailles et
spécialisés justement dans cette
thématique et de la mobilité son but
c'est de rendre accessible la
connaissance de la mobilité à tous et ce
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle on
va en parler dans un instant ça me cry m
déjà une première réaction aux chiffres
que l'on vient d'entendre que qui nous
ont été données par michael est ce qu'il
vous étonne ces chiffres ou finalement
vous avez fait les mêmes constatations
sur sept dernières années avec cette
émergence de la crise sanitaire
non ils sont ils sont pas étonnant du
tout on est vraiment sur les sur les
mêmes constats de notre côté
avec une augmentation effectivement
alors une augmentation absolue de la
voiture mais nous faisons une
augmentation relative de la voiture par
rapport à l'ensemble des flux qu'on peut
on peut observer maintenant
et puis une tendance au fond de l'eau
changement pour le télétravail donc on
verra les conséquences à moyen terme il
pourrait affecter effectivement le
trafic mais dont on voit qu'elle affecte
d'autant plus le trafic pour le
transport en commun que pour la voiture
et ça moi je considérais pas forcément
une très très bonne chose pour pour pour
le transport et la mobilité en
ile-de-france et comment on l'expliquent
à votre avis est-ce que ça peut être
aussi la crainte des franciliens en vue
au vu de ce virus de de se retrouver
justement peut-être dans les transports
en commun et de privilégier justement
des solutions on est seul dans son moyen
de transport complètement on essaye
simplement de se protéger
même si on mais j'ai fait que les
transports en ile de france essaie de
mettre tous les moyens de leur côté pour
protéger les franciliens dans leur
mobilité
mais on voit que c'est jamais très très
facile à mettre en place et donc voilà
les gens se protègent fondu de report
modal plutôt gras la voiture privilégie
le télétravail quand ils le peuvent
en tout cas pour ceux qui le peuvent pas
ce qu on a aussi observé des populations
qui elles ne pouvaient pas
télétravailler et qui étaient aussi des
gens qui étaient souvent contraints aux
transports en commun et pour ces
personnes là qui sont fait souvent sur
les mêmes lignes d'ailleurs de transport
les problèmes ne se sont pas arrangées
un mot sur votre start up qui n' en 2019
sur le plateau de satory ya à versailles
qui est issu des travaux de recherches
devaient d'aecom entropie vise à
faciliter les déplacements du quotidien
alors vous proposer aux opérateurs
transport et aux collectivités un outil
pour connaître mesurer analyser les
besoins en mobilité sur un territoire et
ce grâce à l'intelligence artificielle
comment ça fonctionne très concrètement
ce qui est intéressant c'est que vous
installez aucun matériel lancé via des
données que vous collectez que vous
pouvez proposer cet outil tout à fait
valide et c'est qu'on a créé un
algorithme qui permet de comprendre
comment les gens se déplacent sur un
territoire et à partir de badauds qui on
est
donc c'est très simple c'est qui je suis
moi un homme de 40 ans comment est ce
que je vais avoir besoin de me déplacer
avec un enfant que je dois emmener à
l'école donc j'ai commencé à voir des
eaux à décines et puis nous on a pu
observer qu'en fait il y avait des
profils de mobilité comme ça voilà des
gens qui se déplacent pas par hasard il
ya une structure dans la façon les gens
se déplacent et c'est ça qu'on a voulu
apprendre à ceci on peut si une
structure est bien l'intelligence
artificielle permet de comprendre sa
structure delà de la découvrir en fait
donc on laisse les algorithmes eux
travaillaient là dedans en optimisant
modèle et ça permet à près de prédire
comment les gens se déplacent sur
n'importe quel territoire
donc d'où est-ce qu'ils partent ou est
ce qu'ils vont avec quel mode de
transport pour quel motif ils ont besoin
de se déplacer qui sont les gens qui se
déplacent à quelle heure et tout ça mais
voilà on le rentrer dans notre dos notre
modèle c'est ce qu'ont fourni aux
territoires pour optimiser leurs
systèmes de transport l'idée c'est de
dire nous on va pouvoir leur fournir
comment les gens se déplacent c'est à
dire vraiment vous moi de quoi on a
besoin pour déplacer au quotidien et
pour que les collectivités les
territoires puissent adapter leur
système au plus près de la demande en
transport des usages est-ce que vous
travaillez avec beaucoup d'acteurs dans
les yvelines avec le département on a eu
l'occasion déjà travaillé que le
département aussi avec l'agglomération
de rambouillet pour le territoire avec
l'agglomération de rambouillet par
exemple avec le département on avait pu
observer très très concrètement c'était
on avait observé les flux sur sur ce
territoire là et on s'était aperçu que
baye avait un flux assez dense entre
deux de communes et qui faisait du
report modal vers une station de rer
mais qui n'étaient pas dans le
département des yvelines est et ça va
c'était des données qu'ils n'avaient pas
il ne savait pas si des gens se
déplaçaient à 98 % quasiment en voiture
et pourtant il y avait vraiment de
beaucoup de gens qui se déplacent s
étaient plus de 500 personnes qui
devaient se déplacer tous les jours et
bien en voilà concrètement ça a permis
après la mise en place d'une ligne de
bus dédiés pour que les gens puissent ne
plus avoir à prendre à prendre leur
voiture non puisqu'on qu'on puisse
imaginer des solutions une dernière
question très rapidement c'est un modèle
que vous avez développé à l'échelle
française maintenant qui est dupliqué à
l'échelle européenne csah assez dans
notre roadmap technologique et écouter
oui oui c'est notre ambition on espère
que que très bientôt peut-être en 2022
déjà on pourra se développer à l'europe
merci sa micra est d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous je rappelle co-fondateur et
ceo de la start-up anthropique y est
installée à versailles dans l'actualité
la campagne de vaccination on connaît un
nouveau tournant en france
johnson & johnson retarde le déploiement
de son vaccin en europe annonce
aujourd'hui du laboratoire américain
après que les autorités sanitaires
américaines est préconisé de faire une
pause dans l'utilisation de ce vaccin en
raison de plusieurs cas sévères de
caillots sanguins
la france avait pour rappel annoncé le
déploiement progressif de ce quatrième
vaccin sur le territoire pour faire le
point plus localement dans les yvelines
à la date du 12 avril 192 1628 personnes
ont étés primo vacciner plus de 15000
rendez vous sont prévus pour cette
semaine dont la quasi majorité pour des
deuxième injection de vaccin
c'est un dossier important pour la
commune de la verrière la rénovation du
quartier du bois de l'étang un projet
sur lequel le département des yvelines
garde un oeil attentif en tant que
collectivités engagées dans les
politiques sociales
en attendant le projet du maire fait
toujours débat auprès des habitants du
quartier les détails dans ce sujet de
nicolas landry l'avenir du bois de
l'étang un dossier sur la table de la
municipalité depuis plusieurs années au
coeur d'un débat entre les habitants
avec cette question une rénovation des
bâtiments avec ou sans destruction un
sujet abordé par le président du
département des yvelines pierre bédier
lors de son déplacement dans le quartier
le département était favorable aux
destructions comme la région comme l
état parce que nous savons par
expérience lorsqu'il ya des quartiers
enclavés
on comprend bien l'inquiétude des gens
sur les démolitions
mais le désenclavement est nécessaire
pour que le quartier puissent respirer
pour qu'on puisse mieux et vivre nous
savons par expérience que s'il n'y a pas
ces démolitions le quartier va se
dégrader
aujourd'hui le maire a un projet en tête
la destruction de trois bâtiments sur 10
212 foyers seraient donc concernées par
la charte intercommunale de relogement
ce plan devrait être déposé à l'agencé
nationale de rénovation urbaine courant
mai avec à la clé près de 60 millions
d'euros de financement une zone
commerciale dynamiser un quartier plus
accessible une entrée de ville digne de
ce nom une grande coulée verte pour
renforcer le côté nature des pistes vélo
voilà toutes les ambitions sont
traduites dans ce plan masse
plusieurs habitants sont en désaccord
avec ce projet opposés à la destruction
il préfère une rénovation des bâtiments
existants
ils sont soutenus par le collectif des
locataires qui propose un projet
alternatif
on n'a pas concertés sur ce projet est
une autre comptant aujourd'hui c'est sur
la participation citoyenne déjà du temps
sur ce projet nous on a lu un architecte
nous a fait déjà un projet sont démolis
seront encore plus technique des mondes
elantra taxe sur tous les espaces
extérieurs et donc on essaye d'améliorer
les dysfonctionnements mais sans des
membres font les concertations vont se
poursuivre du côté de la mairie et du
collectif des locataires avec la volonté
de servir au mieux l'intérêt des
habitants de ce quartier là l'île de
france en soutien aux communes la
collectivité a signé à tout récemment
son contrat d'aménagement régional avec
jouy en josas une aide de près de 800
18000 euros qui va servir à financer à
hauteur de 50 % 2 projet porté par la
ville la rénovation du groupe scolaire
du centre et les travaux essentiellement
d'isolation vont durer deux ans et puis
l'aménagement de la place est d'aimer
cet ensemble qui est aujourd'hui un
parking va se transformer en espaces
végétalisés avec un square depuis à 2016
l'ile-de-france a accompagné une
cinquantaine de commune yvelinoise par
le biais de ces contrats écouter ses
interviews
le contrat d'aménagement régional il est
fait pour accompagner les
des communes à répondre aux besoins de
leurs habitants le moindre besoin donc
on l'a beaucoup simplifié depuis qu'on
est arrivé à la tête de la région on a
aussi renforcé les moyens et on a
diversifié les dépenses éligibles donc
maintenant il peut y avoir un équipement
sportif culturel
typiquement les rénovations d'écoles etc
parce que chaque commune a des besoins
évidemment différent la rénovation
énergétique de notre groupe scolaire
était très importante puisque
aujourd'hui on est engagé dans une
démarche de transition depuis de
nombreuses années on a à coeur de faire
ces investissements là parce que ce sont
des investissements qui ne génère des
économies de fonctionnement par la suite
on dépense moins d'énergie moins de
fluides et puis ça va dans le sens de la
préservation de la planète on agit
aujourd'hui pour nos enfants pour demain
pour que la les dépenses d'énergie soit
moins en moins important une école
dédiée à la cybersécurité qui va ouvrir
ses portes en septembre à saint quentin
en yvelines son nom l'école 2600 elle
accueillera dans la première année une
centaine d'apprenants qui seront formés
aux métiers de la cybersécurité un
secteur d'activité en pleine croissance
et avec des forts besoins en compétences
les détails dans cette interview express
collectées par nicolas landry
[Musique]
l'école de 1600 est une école en
alternance qui vise à former des cyber
défenseur ans l'école ouvrira
normalement le 13 septembre dans
l'ancien musée la ville de saint quentin
en yvelines dans le 78 nous visons une
centaine d'étudiants pour la première
promotion qui aura lieu en septembre
2021 la première partie enseignement en
présence à l'école deuxième partie
enseignement à distance
troisième partie présence en entreprise
l'intérêt pour nous était de répondre à
un besoin d'employabilité sûr que les
entreprises ou vifs sont parties
prenantes sur la conception des
programmes de cours qui étaient pour
nous essentiel et plutôt que d'attendre
trois ans pour que la première promo
sont disponibles sur le marché
ça nous permet aujourd'hui d'avoir
aujourd'hui des étudiants qui soit
directement opérables et qui répondent
aux besoins des entreprises ce sera un
titre de niveau 7 qui vaut un bac +5
avec un titre d'experts en gestion des
systèmes sécurité informatique
l'inscription se fait sur le site école
2600 points comme le processus de
sélection est assez strict on va
sélectionner étudiants sur dossier puis
par l'entretien de motivation puis
entretien technique pour être en
capacité d'offrir aux entreprises le
plateau de paris saclay les meilleurs
candidats dans domaine de la
cybersécurité
l'industrie est en tension on a un
manque de 10000 emplois dans le domaine
de la cyber et suite à l'annoncé du
président de la république sur le plan à
milliards pour pouvoir relancer la
filière
on estime qu'il faudra horizon 2025
avoir 45 mille postes dont trente mille
sont vacants le lycée evariste-galois de
sartrouville distingué grâce à cette
affiche ne regarde pas réagi
l'établissement a été primée avec huit
autres projets de l'académie de
versailles dans le cadre du prix non
harcèlement il vise à sensibiliser les
élèves à ce phénomène près de 1200
jeunes se sont mobilisés dans l'académie
qui regroupe les départements des
yvelines de l'essonne des hauts de seine
et du val d'oise des affiches et vidéo
de prévention pour lutter contre toutes
les formes de harcèlement été réalisé
l'ensemble des projets primés au niveau
académique sera présenté au niveau
national et vous précise d'ailleurs
qu'une
werth académique existe pour les
victimes ou témoins d'harcèlement
scolaire le 0 800 00 8 624 appels
gratuits direction gaz rend à présent où
les pas de relais tendresse organise une
activité pour le moins insolite pour ses
90 résidents la chouette thérapie
l'objectif offrir du bonheur aux
personnes âgées en caressant des animaux
le reportage d'eléonore sinoquet deux
animateurs des personnes âgées et des
chouettes
ce sont les ingrédients nécessaires pour
un rendez vous original la chouette
thérapie tous les mois les pattes de gaz
rend organise cette activité pour ses
résidents c'est une activité qui est
complètement insolite puisque on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir des chouettes au des
hiboux régulièrement et on se rend
compte que des résidants qui pourrait
être un peu renfermé qui ne discutent
pas beaucoup et on voit leurs visages
qui s'illumine mise en place depuis 2010
9 grâce au mécénat de l'entreprise
gecina immobilier dix séances d'une
heure environ sont organisées par an à
la manoeuvre le parc animalier l'espace
rambouillet qui compte 150 rapaces le
fait de porter des rivales sauvage dans
une résidence et de faire voler cette
rage au delà de lui faire porter sur le
lent ça ça met en place des émotions des
souvenirs ça fait bouger les résidents
aussi parce qu'il faut soulever tendre
le bras rappeler la chouette ça les met
en valeur lundi 12 avril une vingtaine
de résidents participer à cette chouette
thérapie un bon moyen pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir ces animaux et en apprendre
un peu plus sur eux moi j'adore sur les
animaux alors je suis fait j'étais
contente et j'ai passé une bonne après
enfin à une bonne journée agréable
pourquoi parce qu'on va prendre des
choses toujours sa saisie mais on l'a on
a peur si vous voulez sans avoir peur
c'est absolument génial
il ya deux personnes qui sont vraiment
très cultivé qui nous aura appris
beaucoup de choses
une conférence sur les rapaces est
également organisée avec l'espace
rambouillet d'ici deux semaines dans
l'établissement des activités plutôt
chouette donc que l'ehpad de gaz rang et
ses 90 résidents espère faire perdurer
longtemps et puis cette bonne nouvelle
pour les nageurs à poissy la piscine de
mignot a rouvert ses portes depuis le
samedi 27 mars les habitués étaient bien
sûr ravi de retrouver le bassin
extérieur malgré les températures un peu
froide célia 400 go je suis ravie je me
demande même si chez encore nager
tellement ça fait longtemps que tu peux
aller à la piscine premiers plongeons
depuis six mois
les habitués de la piscine de mignot à
poissy retrouve le bassin extérieur
considérée comme un équipement de plein
air oui ça fait beaucoup de bien on est
super contents que soient rouverts ouais
effectivement j'attendais avec
impatience je regarde je check est
régulièrement le site et d'aigus que
c'était ouvert
j'ai repris depuis la piscine énormément
qu'un de les piscines sont pratiquement
tout faire mais enfin toutes celles qui
n'ont pas de bassins extérieurs
donc on m'attendait que ça très contents
se faisait depuis six mois que ça allait
fermer
voilà ça fait du bien au mental c'est
entre 1h15 et une heure et demie pour
pour le plaisir
ce sont seulement les nageurs de plus de
12 ans qui sont autorisés à venir
trois créneaux horaires sont possibles
chacun pouvant accueillir 84 personnes
maximum
messier de fluidifier aussi un petit peu
l'arrivée des clients c'est vrai que si
on avait une ouverture publique 2010
jusqu'à 18h30
la problématique on a qu'on avait c'est
peut-être un afflux de personnes entre
midi et 14 heures et plus forcément
grand monde en plein milieu d'après-midi
et puisqu'on passe aussi en réservation
recommandée
les personnes voit très bien le taux de
remplissage qu'on peut avoir par créneau
masque désinfection des mains et casiers
individuels obligatoires fléchage et
code couleur pour les entrées/sorties
douche savonnée avant d'aller dans l'eau
un protocole sanitaires strictes a été
établi ce soit aussi trois couloirs au
lieu de 6 pour éviter les croisements
on essaie de tourner à peu près
vingtaine de personnes par linda sachant
que c'est un bassin de 50 mètres donc ça
laisse beaucoup de place à partir de mai
la jauge devraient être augmentés à 200
personnes maximum
la pataugeoire quand elle rouvrira au
mois de juin si les conditions
sanitaires le permettent
et j'ajoute que dans le même secteur la
piscine de porcheville a également
rouvert ses portes car ils disposent
d'un toit ouvrable voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité
très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]